but i genuinely feel like when you look
at most social media millennials are
messed up
let me see if i can pull up this story
let me see if i can try and i'm trying
to find a story we're going to jump
ahead a little bit and i'll tell you how
messed up millennials are here we go oh
this i got this uh tweet where i wrote
brain rot it is a woman
and she's 11.6 million views she posts
on her tic toc lost a patient today
and then she's like she set up the
camera she's filming herself she leans
up against the wall shake it off you
five more hours she's a nurse or
whatever or a doctor i don't know maybe
a fancy doctor and this right here is is
is in my opinion the exact like
the problem with everything it's not
just millennials
it's the younger generation on social
media they're all doing this
they are desperate for validation and
attention and so everything about their
lives is fake made up
this is very scary right so we saw some
tragedies take place in in a couple
cities philadelphia and highland park
and why does that kind of thing happen
well we have to talk about it these guys
want their name in the news they want to
be on tv they want people to know who
they are they want to be a part of
history
they're often loners on antidepressants
things like that so it all makes sense
no one is giving them the time of day
humans are social creatures who crave
social interaction
this is on the same
wavelength
totally opposite ends like okay some
lady made a fake video where she
pretended to mourn and it's very vapid
and all that stuff fine she didn't go
and hurt anybody so they're very very
different but there's a similar thread
stitching these things in that people
are they will do whatever it takes to
get those likes on social media so that
they can feel validated because they
don't have the mental fortitude to feel
good about themselves on their own this
is the millennial generation gen z is
very similar
all of these i remember i went to vidcon
i think it was like 2016
and there were these little kids so this
is eight years ago this is six years ago
this is crazy
there were a bunch of little kids and as
i'm walking past and one goes how many
followers do you have i have 43 and he
goes i got 82. you have 82 followers and
i was like those kids are going to be
messed up
that's where we're going garyvee will
tell kids that don't worry about the
number of followers you have focus on
the quality and having fun and being
happy and making things like but this
this video is a perfect example of why
the country is imploding and it really
really is think about it
what we see with virtue signaling the
woke people ellen page you better you
better delete that viral trend because
you said the wrong name yo
99 of people i i guarantee you if you
walk down the street in any major city
and said do you know who elliot page is
they'd be like no and if you said do you
know allen pages they'd be like oh yeah
yeah from x-men like did you know that
it's bigoted to say that name they'd be
like i have no idea yet those people
would innocently go on twitter and say
something like big fan of ellen page in
those movies she is super cool and then
banned not allowed
that's happening because these people
are like i'm gonna get attention here's
a really good example did you guys see
that what's his name griffin green you
guys hear about this guy you heard about
him right uh bodega bro oh oh yeah i
didn't know his real name i only knew
bodega bro bodega bro so there's this
dude this is an amazing story he moves
to new york for a job and he's this
really kind of like
i don't know what the right word is
doofy like it's like an endearing kind
of um
uh general ignorance okay i'm not i'm
not in something i'm saying he just
didn't understand new york so it's
probably a good thing to be ignorant of
for sure new york city but so he's
walking around and he's like i'm trying
to find a grocery store in new york i
can't find anything and he's like it
keeps google maps keep sending me to
these places he's like yo what's going
on and it's like they're making
sandwiches a bodega
someone
reported him to his company and they're
like are you going to employ this person
so they fire him
people get mad at this dude who reported
him and so then that dude makes a video
where he's like i'm being harassed on
the internet you have no idea what it
feels like when people are coming after
you it's like bro you just did this
these people their brains are are putty
it's mush
they're going on social media and
they're like i'm gonna get attention by
tattletailing on someone and then it's
just a big swarm of people
flinging crap at each other yeah all for
the sake of getting more clicks getting
more attention to the point where yo
someone died i don't actually know if
someone died she could be faking it but
you're going to be wearing your scrubs
frame your camera get it set up press
record look back check your hair stand
back and then go oh someone's the same
callousness yeah and different human
life i think
really what's happening here
to me anyway my impression is that we've
really just commodified connection which
is something that ultimately we really
need like you said we're
we are social creatures so
all humans need connection and so as our
as our technology gets more and more
advanced that that is supposed to
ironically bring us together more and
more uh we are ironically being sort of
forced apart
more so and especially since the
pandemic so you know that combined that
with the american tendency to
um
i mean this is going back to my my
college days of of sociology classes
that i took um on like our our american
um cultural roots of being um uh
cultural roots and calvinism and and um
uh puritans and that kind of stuff that
like they would look for signs of being
being uh part of the the the saved you
know the the part of the you know going
yeah
yeah exactly the elect reaching
salvation and whatnot they will look for
signs for that being like you know signs
of of wealth it means that you're not
spending your money it means that you
are accumulating your wealth means that
you are working very hard very
diligently so those were all virtues so
we just as a as a culture from our very
very cultural early historical
underpinnings we have um had a long
tradition of sort of commodifying our
virtues so
it makes a lot of sense that in the age
of social media in the age of likes and
subscribes and shares that that's the
way that we'll we'll view those virtues
of of having connection having a
personal connection with with other
individuals and it and especially
um like a clip like that that has a lot
of emotion involved in it i mean we're
talking about death we're talking about
grief that is a pretty strong um i guess
you could say force for somebody to want
to
give some kind of connection to that
kind of emotion
i think uh
you're you're right about the
commodification of virtue and all stuff
but there was a uh uh
a unified message in this country so
that commodification was mostly unified
a single track when the dixie chicks i
think it was do you know the dixie
chicks are yeah you do okay when they
came out i think they criticized the war
right that's what happened yeah the
warner george w bush and then it was
like it was a bad thing you got
cancelled yeah they got cancelled now
that now they're just trying to go by
the chicks yeah now they're just we were
joking me and brett were joking that
like you can't call women chicks anymore
you can't it's offensive uh but back
then
even though
most like you democrats republicans and
you had a big anti-war movement the
mainstream narrative was
don't rag on the soldiers or criticism
of the war was criticism of the soldiers
something happened and i think it has to
do with the internet
where
a divergent culture emerged we split
and two markets developed you had a
market for
out angst and wokeness and you had a
market for
opposing it free speech liberty freedom
all that stuff kind of where we ended up
and then
that that market split
it probably could have been stopped if
in the in the late 2000s
someone came out was like yo yo yo yo we
are we're hard forking here as an
american culture but no one did anything
so american culture forked and i think
it's a lot to do with in cities with the
internet messaging spread so rapidly
that the left dramatically changed their
position
faster than the right could keeping keep
in line with it there's a good there's a
good example i can maybe pull up in a
second from the new york times where it
shows in 2008 the left veers off like
that and the right just keeps going
when that happened
you end up with tens of millions of
people all with money creating a massive
market opportunity for woke virtue
signaling
that will never stop
so at this point i would i would say you
know i was trying to i was wondering
like how do we stop the country from
collapsing like what are the real
solutions and and i don't want to say
it's blackpill to think this i think
it's more realism
you can't and the reason is
there is money to be made if you are
woke there is money to be made if you
are anti-woke this means that market
forces and political forces necessitate
the expand the expansion of messaging in
favor of these two massive groups you
could disincentivize money and focus
more on goods and services i think
that's a that's something that could
keep us together it's how do we get the
grain from kansas around the country so
we can all eat
that and i mean
there's also the the possibility that
people get oversaturated by it and
people get tired of it and then
eventually they want to find something
that is a little bit more more moderated
i just watched a documentary on buzzfeed
uh yesterday i think it was yesterday
before and how they were really leading
spearheading this what you were calling
a commodification of of well that's
called hate or whatever but like 2012 13
it's like uh identity politics they'd be
like
25 things that black people can identify
with 12 things that women really want
18 things a gay man can get down with
and you're like all of a sudden it's
getting then it's like a black gay man
and then
this hate gets involved like four things
that you just women just can't stand and
then boston bombing people are profiting
off of the news
anyway i could go on i'm gonna break
that down i want to show this real quick
and then explain what ian's saying so
this is
what happened to the the political
center from the new york times and you
can see in 2008
the left the democratic party look at
look at that chart just look at that the
blue line
shooting super far left you see which is
median party that's the median party of
europe so the united states for some
reason in eight years
became left of center for european
political parties which are already
relatively far left now of course the
left will look at that and say oh see
we're only center left the republican
party is far right and it's like no no
that's american culture you can disagree
with it but this show is the left went
far left relative to where americans are
and i'll tell you how it happened as
zean was pointing out
buzzfeed was creating articles where it
was like about black people about gay
people those were buzz words
the algorithm would latch onto words
and then pump them out and what happens
i remember this man you guys probably
remember this too i don't know if you
remember this all the police brutality
videos
all that's all facebook was it was like
you'd go on facebook and it was just
endless videos of police brutality rap
songs about police brutality that's all
it was
so what happens is you get companies
like buzzfeed where they're like hey we
got a million clicks in that police
brutality video why well because people
don't like injustice then they were like
hey hey i made an article that was
talking about police brutality and
racism got twice as many views
so they start cramming all the different
keywords as possible into as many
articles as possible
and then you get intersectional feminism
and it's not and then they'll be like
hey there's no racist violent things
that happened today what's our next
article going to be it's not that
they're going out there and creating the
racist violence necessarily but there is
an incentive to see more racist violence
and you will literally as a as a someone
that does that stuff hope for something
like that to happen so that you can make
a lot of money off it it's considered so
here's here's the fight here's the
political battle can you can you pull
this back up the new york times thing
if you are in the middle of the road
um from 2000 you're let's say you were
the democrat you weren't a republican
you were a moderate you're in between
you likely did not get pulled far left
along with the democratic party you
probably floated somewhere in the middle
like this like me maybe to to a certain
extent a bit like ian or a bit like joe
rogan or elon musk so now
if you were in the middle
the republican party well
they're kind of right wing compared to
where i am but the left i can't even see
where they're at
so this is what happens there was a
tweet from libby evans about how the
democrats went so pro-abortion that a
lot of people just were like like
democrats were like yo i'm out and they
lost the fight they had no support
anymore and then i see this on twitter
the commodification of virtue the
centrists are just far right the center
has moved far right the the moderates
are being radicalized and i'm just like
if you are in the democratic party and
you veered that far left you don't think
you moved you're the same normal person
you've always been it's like if you go
underwater and then you look up at
people on the surface you're like
everyone's blurry now
exactly but like dude that's cause get
out of the water and everyone's still
normal man
so here's the issue though these people
they built a following
they've got millions of followers they
can't just stop cnn
they used to be they used to cover the
news now it's just orange man bad all
day every day january 6 and whatever
they can milk out of it
if cnn
comes out now and says we're going to go
back to report in the news no one will
watch them because they'll lose the
zealot fans they got and they already
lost the news fans they well they lost
them a long time ago so they have no
choice in addiction and they've done it
to themselves yeah i was just i was just
thinking that i think that an important
factor in that is the the actual
emotional addiction or maybe not
emotional but the addiction that some
people actually have to
to these emotions that they feel
um
with regard to these these uh various
stories rage is a big one um what's her
face that uh when she she testified in
front of congress about facebook um this
was i don't know how many months ago um
one of the she was a former she was
supposed to be working on their like oh
right their electrical blower yeah yeah
yeah the facebook wasn't a quote yeah um
but she was talking about that how she
she had said that there was there was
some kind of studies i'm i'm i'm really
reaching back without having looked at
this after months but um as she was
saying that that was that was one of the
one of the one of the big issues is that
is that people were actually having
their they were showing signs of
addiction to
to rage and so it's like how do you get
somebody off of that
off of that sort of a substance when
it's everywhere and there's every
incentive for them to continue profiting
off of it well so there there are um
dave rubin's got this joe rogan's got
this i've obviously got this there are
people who take clips out of context on
purpose
because they know there's a market for
tribal rage yeah so we try to have
people on the left on this show and
we've had a few but
i would say the overwhelming majority of
them won't come on they'll cancel they
refuse or they'll use it to rally their
base because they're virtuous ignorers
so there's one guy in particular who's
like oh come on and then when we
actually were like okay sure he he
privately says i'm not actually doing it
then goes to his fans and blames me for
for not allowing it and now uses that to
rile them up and say see see what i told
you and it's crazy because i'm like yo
we genuinely tried to have some of these
people on and they legit spit on us and
laughed and said now we're gonna make
money off you then they go to their base
and say they were the actual bad guys so
this is the crazy thing
we are trying to get those people out of
the cult
they think we're in the cult but these
are the people who believed jesse smilet
these are the people who believed
russiagate these are the people who
believed hands up don't shoot these are
the people who believe the covington
kids story these are the people who
believe ukraine gate these are the
people who believe the very fine people
hoax these are the people who never once
stopped to actually check the evidence
themselves
and there are many of them and they have
money and their money is easily parted
from them by these people that is the
big challenge and so long as there are
these prominent left-wing personalities
who will pander to them
there's there's going to be a division
that is moving us towards catastrophe
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you